welcome to the first new episode of the
corridor cast where we get together and
well be ourselves so we're gonna do that
today here wasn't myself on the last one
yeah well you were you were it's just
it's been a while since that last one
and I wanted to get back to one of those
yeah we've had a lot of guests but you
know what I think it's time where we
collectively do an episode guests are
interesting but so you guys are also
interesting breaking all the rules today
we've got laptops we've got discussion
topics but we can you know we're just so
we're just gonna go for it all right
let's play a game let's play a game
can we start with something let's say
can we start with this thing that I was
talking about net might not my topic
fine yeah let's start with you because
let me introduce this introduce lost in
my brain all morning so y'all might have
heard earlier this week there was a
college entrance cheating scam
yes this is Sam's topic a slew of
business executives and high-profile
celebrities are amongst more than 40
people charged with 20 within a 25
million dollar cheating scheme for
students to gain admission to high level
institutions such as Yale Stanford USC
blah blah blah and absolutely no one is
surprised okay yeah so no one is
surprised no one is surprised here is
the best part about this is that
apparently in addition to cheating on
the AC T and SAT on behalf of students
and bribing coaches and administrators
people also went to the length of in
some instances pictures of students
playing sports were staged and some
pictures even used Photoshop to insert
applicant spaces onto the bodies of real
athletes Wow yeah okay so that all
there's a lot of stuff you said there
that is stuff that I was unaware of when
I initially broached this topic because
what like where I was at here before
before learning some of this was I read
a thing about a celebrity being arrested
and put on 1 million dollar bail because
she paid some money to get her kid into
USC ok and so first off you already pay
money to get in the USC a lot of it and
she she paid yeah she paid much more
than normal but once again it's a
private university
so I'm like why is she being arrested
like is it illegal to bribe a private
university official yes okay so but but
what if like he just she just pays
someone off the street like what makes a
private university official like somehow
illegal to give money to because they're
held to us like they're held to a code
of conduct to me I have a school if you
pay me $500 I'll let you into it I know
but well that's not illegal so yeah you
know it's definitely a gray area but the
the first and foremost thing that you're
forgetting Sam in this cuz you were
asking him about this earlier and the
whole question is is it is it illegal
and what is illegal
yeah what's legal versing first and
foremost it's fraud yeah you're
misrepresenting so not only is it fraud
on behalf of the person at the
institution that's taking the money
because they're they're a fraud is a
misrepresentation of a material fact
that causes somebody else to act based
upon that misrepresentation okay so that
is what happened so that is fraud as in
someone took money at an institution and
then said okay now I'm going to turn
around and pretend that this person has
X amount of score on the AC T and is X
amount good at export okay and I'm going
to represent that to the institution so
they're they're guilty of fraud and the
person that paid them is guilty of
bribery and racketeering sure because
you created a racket that you created a
scam you've created a scam because
there's a middleman involved etc etc but
but but usually like when you think
about fraud here fraud is usually like
hey Clint if you give me a million
dollars I'll give you a golden house
alright and you get it you get it in the
house isn't gold and you're like you
hear that was fraud that's fraud but
this is the other way around oh it's
like Clint check this out how about this
I will give you a million dollars if I
give you a golden house all right and
you're like okay I don't lose anything
right you get I get a ton of money but
then discounts that discounts like you
know everyone else involved in the
school I think it's more that's like
what about the neighborhood you know
like I guess so I guess what about the
what about the other students that
potentially who advertises
working a certain way yes and they
aren't working that way that's false
advertising which is fraud I guess
here's the exact thing that here's an
actual allegation that came out of this
apparently former full house star Lauri
Lachlan and her husband designer Massimo
which y'all were wearing though jeans
but wait wait really that's the monster
[Laughter]
apparently those two paid five hundred
dollars five hundred thousand dollars to
have their two daughters selected as
recruits for the USC crew team despite
the fact that neither of them
participated in crew ever so they
they're there this the photos connect
the two directly in this NBC article but
it would seem like they went on the
growing photo shoot at least at the very
least they went on a rowing photo shoot
but like think about this though like
how screwed to those kids you know sure
sure
mom and dad put me through this and like
I knew I couldn't do it so they had to
lie but and then the kids apparently
didn't even know about it
apparently oh yeah yeah sometimes some
of the parents were apparently just
paying to have the grades on this on the
standardized tests amended and not
telling their kids yes mom why are we
doing this tennis photo shoot like I
don't even play tennis league trust me
you're gonna need this for your dad's
fashion line through dad's father's
first of all see mens brand and I'm not
a man well they're expanding yeah so the
age of gender diversity they're
expanding out just put on the jeans
someone once told me a story about where
they were flying a wall in the meeting
at USC with some of the higher-ups and
they're talking about what they should
raise their tuition to for the next year
they said like all right well let's pull
up all the other most expensive private
schools all right now it's like okay
cool that's what the price is we'll set
our s be 5% higher than that because we
need to still be the best and that's
we'll just pick the most expensive price
that's there for the best yeah and
that's why I and then of course there's
why are you raising tuition they had
this whole like you know gathering where
they explain what costs are going up
yeah you know just bullshitting
everybody on it and ever since I heard
that story I've just I've had no respect
for that school yeah well not to mention
when you read deeper into some of these
articles you see oh by the way when she
was arrested or like the night before
this actress was arrested her daughter
was partying on a boat that was owned by
one of the board of trustees at USC so
it's like dude first off first off
herself I know why parent as a parent
myself I understand
trying to get your kid an edge and all
that stuff but like I feel like the
order of operations for the way this
stuff gets released here it's like first
off the kid needs to be expelled okay
like that's variously that's like the
like that's the true ultimate punishment
now he's end it on merit so yeah and now
let's go to the person at USC who is
supposed to be held to a certain
standard because of this institution
should be fined and the laws that
government accredited universities in
the US and all that stuff and then at
the very end of this line here of look
of our order of operations here it's
like alright now let's deal with how we
handle the parents like did they do a
fraudulent donation that was a write-off
that they actually paid etc etc I just
think this whole thing is like kind of
backwards right now because ultimately
it stems from people at the university
being corrupt because yes when they amp
and that's really the big story here
yeah USC has a lot of corrupt people
right handling their admissions or at
least a lot of people who don't
understand how Photoshop works and
they're like that face the lighting
doesn't match but you know what I'll
take that as proof of I'll take those
stats on the crew - yes I never had
those when I was a youngster come on in
I just keep singing back to those kids
that like especially if they didn't know
especially they know like what what I
mean you spell like know that would like
tear apart their relationship with their
with their family no you need to have a
more entitled accent when you're saying
what what more like what laughter you're
telling me that's really okay it's crazy
though that like if they didn't know and
that's just like it's wrong on that like
the the the mistrust and like they would
just totally feel yeah trade by there
but unfortunately I don't I don't I
don't think that any of this is like an
isolated incident you
it's it's probably not that they had
like a perfect upbringing and trust 100%
with their parents and all things and
then all of a sudden one day mom and dad
just pulled the rug out from under you
it's probably like most of the time
these situations are like a cycle of
habit where one thing triggers the
person to get caught but I can see it
being where it's like we want to do
what's best for a kid we want to do
what's best for our kid and they just do
that and they do that and they get the
money so unfortunately the Hollywood
definition of do what's best for your
kid is just completely upside down
obviously we went into a dark zone yeah
we're in the dark zone now yeah like
this I'm not saying that this is a nice
reaction I'm just like trying to get
into the minds of like how this could
have happened you know like it probably
starts with the genes it sucks for the
kids with emotional company especially
if they didn't know already you guys
actually surprised though I mean dowsley
know now so why is it why is it a big
deal now is it just because somebody got
arrested this is why I brought this up
because I sit there and I read the
article and I'm like well first off just
explain to me what's what exactly
happened that was illegal here because
you have a private university and a mom
who wanted to pay extra to an already
super expensive school and like I get
how that's unfair
but what's why is she arrested with a
$1,000,000 flaw because it's fraud and
bribery I guess I fell any you know I
see how we get there it's most but it
stems from it stems from probably the
laws that govern like USC right no those
are jet those are those are laws just on
the books like common law prohibits
bribery but no common law thing common
what is the fraud that's occurring it's
a material misrepresentation caused by a
bribery you're paying some weight you're
saying you're saying hey Nico you're an
administrator at USC I'm Lori Lachlan
full house star here's $500,000 for you
to miss represent the athletic abilities
of my children so that they can attend
the institution for what you are an
administrator so you're committing fraud
and I'm committing bribery so that you
can commit that fraud therefore I am
making an accessory
therefore I'm also guilt
a fraud yeah so what's what's what's
preventing I'm just going we'll do
regular admissions also if you want to
assign $1,000 what you're kidding no
that's because that that's a
contradictory to everything America
stands about yeah but that's not like
it's George W Bush got accepted to both
Yale and Harvard well his father was a
legacy let's start there so so in other
words it wasn't on the merit of the guy
applying there's a it's a loose
definition that's absolutely true but
just paying cold hard cash I mean this
is basically what Facebook tried to do
to us where they're like hey guys do you
want money in exchange for video posting
and it's like well maybe if you guys did
something for the creators like we might
be more interested but now you're just
whoring us out but and the same things
happening here it's like just paying
money just paying cold hard cash so that
your kid can get into an institution not
only is it illegal but it's also like
completely contracted it's illegal to
but but this is this is what I'm trying
to figure out still I mean obviously
this might the aunt the true answer
might be deep down in a law somewhere
but basically like who you know like we
know who the victim is here the victim
is potential applicants with actual like
you know good grades and prerequisites
etc and the country when the country
upholds these institutions as your
bastion of education yeah sure but I
guess there must be your I mean of the
difference between a bribe and a payment
is basically a bribe is subverting a
system in order to get your goals
basically and just a payment is you know
is doing it legally he assumed the
assumed correct way but there so I mean
you're right through this was also
probably a US code on the way that these
institutions are allowed to run
especially since they're public
institutions well no not only is there
probably a federal code and a state code
against yeah it's also just illegal
before common laws that's that's
basically what I'm getting at is reason
there must be some law clearly then
governing how these institutions are
allowed to handle Campbell yeah there's
all kinds of laws that govern how how
institutions govern candidates there's
like been like huge like remember like
tight there's title nine and there's
like affirmative action and there's been
all these things over the last
years that have affected the way that
public universities and private can can
accept students okay because this is
this is the real meat of what I'm
getting at here because like you zoom
out and you're just like crazy mom pays
double to get college for her key you
know and it's kind of like yeah the
problem is that it's not it'll never be
an exact science because it's based upon
like a number of factors yeah and so
there's a number of things that the that
the institutions consider when admitting
somebody but obviously just there's a
line somewhere sure
okay clearly crossed it they definitely
crossed it I'm tired of all this
negative news let's talk about something
cool okay all right ready we're going to
see I just want to play a game or do you
want to talk about a new product new
product I'm so like consumerist well
it's a cool thing
so basically question is buy it or not
all right the one wheel one one wheel
just announced a new one wheel the one
wheel pint in order to become more
accessible to their current niche
audience okay what more accessible than
just their current okay it is reported
to be less clunky AE you don't have to
take an uber ride when it runs out of
batteries and it's more affordable at
nine hundred and fifty dollars but you
only get six to eight miles of range
with a top speed of 16 miles an hour so
is $950 actually affordable and should
people buy it okay time to shine top
speed of 16 bet you can go faster than
that because like the top speed on the
v1 was like 15 or something top speed on
the XR is like some number that we've
always we always break that speak it's
all the same it's just they don't want
you to everybody talks about nose-diving
in the one wheel in reality all it is is
he just over torquing the motor yeah
they're just trying to get you not to go
too fast
yeah it's easier which Clint has done oh
I almost broke my house broke my arm I
remember that was in a brace for it also
it almost broke a camera I'm a camera a
second day I got my a7r team how do you
exceed the top speed lean forward too
far dude okay so check this out I tell
story me and ran were in Pasadena like
just try and break with speed records
right and like the other the
dated on the have speed records on the
app yeah but they took them off because
it's too dangerous but like basically
Wow like they were updated like you know
you're on the app you're scrolling up
and like we're just trying to break the
records and then like you see me in
rennes namely climbing like dude nice
and like we're going on this like
straightaway by a city hall and then all
the sudden I I just I pass right and he
starts screaming like what and I look
first place 28 miles an hour on the v1
you were going downhill no it was flat
Wow it the second day the second day was
the Dales with you guys this and I had
my new camera I was like yeah broke the
speed record I got my new my new cameras
around my shoulder let's go and I just
like hey guys watch this and I just take
off and all of a sudden like did you
guys see the response I can replay this
perfectly alright yeah go for it yes
there's probably splits to save their
sparks just real quick here the way one
wheel works you're on a platform there's
the tire in the middle so when you lean
like when it rolls forward Newton's laws
of motion there's an opposite reaction
the board is going to tilt back says
torque the torque is pushing against the
board but your weight is on the board
and so basically it's just playing a
balancing act of you lean forwards so
the motor torques in the opposite
direction pushing you back up the more
you lean the more the motor has to
torque now if you're going really fast
and the motors already spitting you out
at like 20 miles an hour down the street
and you lean forward even further well
somehow that motor has to spin even
faster and Clinton's here riding down
the street I'm on a bike he's in front
of me and he's leaning forward and he's
leaning forward and he's leaning forward
and then the nose hits and Clint's a
pretty graceful guy so the nose hits
Clint's probably going like 23 miles an
hour so I'm like that do you know how
fast you were going probably that yeah
yeah let me get thrown off and I
remember just one solid stomp like your
foot just comes down hard on the
pavement just you stop as hard as you
can because now you're going into a full
sprint from standing 100 meters pace get
that one stomp in and then your bodies
are you starting to tilt forward and
like from there you go into a tuck and
your camera is on a strap around your
neck in the centrifugal force your body
spinning as you go into this diving
as the cameras straight out arms like as
he spin around and he managed to go down
your shoulder and the camera was made
like whips into the crack and you flip
back up and you actually like ran out of
it if I'm not mistaken that always
happens though like I always dive roll
it and it like looks cool but I'm like
dude that hurts so bad you slap the
ground with your hand bah and like I
dude that night oh my god that night
dude I went to bed and I woke up at like
3:00 in the morning it's covered in
sweat I'm covered in sweat I was like oh
my god my hand hurts so bad and I was
like I started to get nauseous and like
I couldn't stop sweating I could about
to throw up it hurts so bad I couldn't
go back to sleep so I just went urgent
care and they're like dude yeah like
there's like a hairline like hairline
little fracture like like that maybe it
was like it was just a really bad sprain
basically what they said like so so the
one-wheel pine so that you did you did
28 miles an hour on a v1 yeah what's
your reported top speed was 15 I believe
so you don't look it up but okay just
for reference my top speed in the XR is
twenty point three miles an hour okay so
so so is this one we will pint better
now it's back on topic I'm just like
nothing you know you sprained your hand
not while getting state records for each
board of the v1 is 12 miles an hour
okay so why are you but you can really
go 25 so this reported speed is 15 or 16
so I would probably go damn near 30 on I
know not true it's the same motor isn't
it yeah I wouldn't I would not go that
fact like I'm not trying to do speed
records again
like I feel comfortable at 18 19 and
then like the fasiqun I was like 21 on
the XR so so so is a six to eight mile
range far enough so here's what's
special about the point on one hand like
to the consumer
it's a 950 dollar one wheel and like you
only get to that price range if you're
looking for like a used v1 or maybe
a really good deal on a plus but what's
more special about the pint is that it's
the company huge remotion the guys make
one wheel it's them it's starting to
modernize their production of these
things because right now all the one
wheels are like handcrafted hand mailed
in like San Jose California it looked
like it yeah well they're built like it
to like each one's like a tank
but like clearly it's really expensive
and time-consuming to make each one
wheel and so the pint is them now like
taking their assembly process and
updating it and making it less expensive
and finally getting a little bit more
into the mass production market and
doing a good job of it it's a little bit
smaller it's only four pounds lighter
it's basically just a one wheel plus and
a little bit smaller it's just
everything's been updated it with how
they make it so it's a little bit more
of a inexpensive one wheel to make
HELOCs got one next door yeah Alex Knoll
oh yeah I can't wait to try it out as
you received it yet it's about three
months yeah Peter okay but uh I hear
it's zippier because it's the same motor
it's lighter four pounds lighter and you
can travel with it yeah because of like
the battery regulations on them yeah and
so Airlines it's a 160 FAA limits
batteries you can't bring batteries on
an airplane it's more than 160 watt
hours and so the pint is 144 watt hours
the XR is 320 watt hours no trouble with
that yeah yeah I think it's cool
can't wait to try it and so also if you
guys pre-ordered our sweatshirts thank
you very much we'll be having more cool
stuff come out this year at corridor
digital dot store but for those of you
pre-ordered that sweatshirt it'll be
coming to you soon it's super comfy the
stores popping off dude like a lot of
good stuff going on this year keep an
eye some cool stuff works all right yeah
let's play that game all right JT so you
may have heard but the Boeing 737 max 8
and Max 9 jet has been pretty much
grounded globally hmm since I on Monday
there was a second crash in six months
which now combined victims of the crash
over 300 people have died so the FAA
just yesterday said we're gonna ground
them to along with Canada and the EU and
pretty much every other kind
so the entire fleet is almost grounded
now and and according to investigations
at least of the first crash in October
which reportedly the Ethiopian crash
that happened Monday the same thing was
happening
the pilots were wrestling with the plane
because a faulty sensor automatically
pointed the nose of the plane down while
the pilots struggled to lift it up oh my
god while in autopilot so yeah well I
don't know if there's another crash that
happened years ago it's a similar thing
dude that's so so what would you do not
to laugh but what would you do if you
were in a plane that was pointing down
and you were trying to keep it up try to
find the button to turn off the computer
I guess there's an FM switch that you
you can turn off to disable it but like
no one ever uses it and you have to be
trained noise you gotta go full auto or
full manual yeah yeah so yeah it's worth
talking about the mechanics of the stall
for a second here so you know a stall is
when air is not passing over the wings
fast enough and you're no longer you
basically have control of the airframe
because your ailerons and everything
doesn't work it's not necessarily a lack
of lift it's a lack of control and there
was a an airplane crash a jetliner crash
that happened I came after how many
years ago I think the crash into the
ocean and you can there's a transcript
of it which is actually pretty crazy to
read and the pilots think don't know
they're in a stall and they're
constantly pulling back there lies a
plane not going up why's the plane not
going up they're just pulling back on
the the Styx the whole time not knowing
that they're just making things worse
worse because they don't have any
control so the planes not tumbling it's
just lowering and just going down down
they're just pulling up lowering because
it will just get a malfunction they're
not going fast enough to generate lift
and then their controls they're pulling
up but it's not gonna do anything
because they have no control is slowing
down well there are there already
installed that what they thing is they
didn't know it and so the planes
actually trying to go down because what
you need to do in your install is you
need to tilt the nose down gain speed
which causes air to move over the wings
again which then gives you control on
the airplane again you need air to move
over the wings that's all that really
matters just moving more the wings don't
you need lift just just you control once
you have control then you can gain speed
you can get left but the plane was going
down with the nose up because they're
pulling back the whole time like oh
we're losing altitude we won't do that
we need to keep pulling up and so
there's their planes just just belly
flopping into the ocean
yeah and so you know since then they've
updated things they change things that's
a little bit of what you're getting here
is a stall override the plane stalling
so the the software's kicking and going
oh no you're not gonna get a pull-up
anymore which is a human instinct I
don't wanna go down pull up you know
it's like when you tilt the nose down
and get control and we can get out of it
but the issue is that they had you know
faulty readings from the measurements
because I was all set up dang you know
it's super terrifying but you know this
is also why I'm getting into flight
simulators right now no joke because I
was watching that fire festival
documentary and so uh what'd I forget
the name of the guy he was like Dutch or
something the logistics guy the pilot
remember you know yeah he used the guy
who was he told them how many
porta-potties they needed and then they
fired him a little throwaway line which
was like oh yeah I learned how to fly in
Microsoft Flight Simulator I've been a
pilot ever since I'm like wow I'm like
hold the phone you're telling me I can
get a lot of my flight knowledge from a
flight simulator like and it's like it
just never clicked I thought that was
always like a recreational thing is ice
I've been diving into it with like
explain oh my god is it hard no well I
mean yes but no but it's just right they
are waiting freedom to learn old dad I
don't want to get my pilot's license one
day this would be a really great way to
basically know a lot of stuff before you
get there ahead of the game you remember
you get way ahead of the game and I'm
listening to a Skye who's going through
all like the tutorials he's made all
these YouTube videos and he actually has
a pilot's license yeah so you talk see
talks through it and I was like yep
that's right yep that's right yep that's
right
and then that one's kind of right I like
to go 80 not certain versus 75 and this
you know like little things like that
yeah but dude see now now everything
Niko said you got to keep this software
out of the hands of Isis guys hey you
know who else learned how to fly
that guy who hijacked we was stole that
plane over in Seattle no seriously he
learned how to fly that plane bag it's a
bag man the bag crazy yeah yeah he went
on a flight in a flight simulator and
then stole the plane he's supposedly
suicidal he's like I'm gonna go for a
joyride in this thing I have an idea of
how it works I'm not gonna worry about
landing it and like yeah he managed to
do tricks of the game flight simulator
yeah mm-hmm Wow did he land what
happened I don't know anybody crash he
crashed it into an island yeah but he
stole a plane I mean you did a loop with
it he was doing flips with it he like
went bonkers one day he was a baggage
guy he's bonkers one day grabbed a plane
and took off and then like because I'm
talking to him on the on the radio eyes
doing all this kind of plane I don't
know I don't know let me see if I can
find it charlie sounds incredible like a
little Cessna thingy Vegas man plane
right Eggman plane leading up to yeah
there you go hear audio a big holy wow
this is way more intense than I thought
it was damn Kevin O'Leary yeah we don't
even get plain ads on the plane oh no
he's good whoa yeah whoa can you hear
can you can you meet it well yeah
because we probably can't use this stuff
read like it's three domains that is not
that's it we're just getting we're
getting like the the whoa it's that kind
of plane that's serious so he probably
looked at this plane every day and
became infatuated with it and then
daylight simulator with it he's like you
know what there's gonna be great one day
God look at this yeah he did a barrel
roll yeah
already here's some audio here's some
these freaking shoot missiles am
he realizes that people care about him
when he's up there just a bra goddamn
about that right cells like you need
wire from Parks and Rec Wow anyway all
right Wow so anyway they had a whole
conversation eventually it didn't end
the way that the negotiator you try and
land it obviously just like nah no I
think he just flew it until around yeah
yeah it's basically suicide by plane
crash sad but uh beautiful Sims flying
around in this like beautiful sunset
like any huge plane you want to
encourage other people who are suicidal
to steal planes
I mean first off stealing things really
hard you should you should call it
beautiful but I don't think it is I
think it's trap I'm not encouraging I
mean the guy's an idiot the foot is just
beautiful look let's be story's tragic
funky things happen and throughout
history especially looking back on
things from you know from time this is
one of those things that there's some
there's something beautiful about it I'm
not celebrating a man's death
but there's something unique in a guy
getting to go out there height like
stealing a blue ball thought about it
come on let's be real we've all thought
about what if I just ran and jumped in
that cockpit could I fly the plane oh no
way I'm never thought about that
what no way where I can't fly a plane
I'm you
because the pilots you never below seven
like what if I had to jump in their
secret Asian style and fly that thing
what would you do
I've thought about like if a plane went
down in the water and like I had a bus
door open and hold my breath like I
thought about that but I never bought
like that's like a plane I don't want to
fly all right
somebody filming like from a little like
puddle hopper in Hawaii in the plane
like they're flying in like the engines
die and they end up crash landing in the
water the person is filming the whole
time with their phones yeah I'm like
from flight all the way to getting out
of the plane in the ocean yeah yeah all
right what would you do that was yeah we
played the expansion the expansion pack
we never actually got to the core the
core game I did the deal see all right
think about that one clip of the
skydivers that all are rolling GoPros
and the two planes collided yeah yeah
and then everybody survived because
they're all wearing parachutes but it's
like by far the craziest video on
YouTube I got to see that I haven't seen
that chair pull it up no we don't have
audio don't need audio just wind and
explosion sounds Jake hasn't seen this
this is the best video on you go throw
non-lethal aviation airplane collision
GoPro skydiving cold air plane collision
collection collision collision you got
it you got it
boom that's a amazing skydivers land
safely this is by far the craziest video
on YouTube
can you pull this under the no you don't
need audio just no pull it onto the feet
yeah cut that into and later on oh dude
it's like you know you're okay but what
about your buddies yeah yeah yeah let's
see the alternate angle
everybody's got GoPros which is like
crazy part like also alternate angle
both planes so get out get out Oh No
please the screen look at that shot yeah
look at that shot it's incredible like
all these people skydiving like the
planes like going down in flames behind
them oh we're doing crazy land yeah
above land I mean they are above land
somewhere on the ground look at that guy
hanging on the frickin just eating toast
how did the pilot get out the muscles
just bailed and they come whoops a guy
like hold on oh my god what did the
pilots do jumped out they jumped out and
they got caught Oh probably yeah yeah he
must have been like dolphin catch me I
wanna know
landed no one died no one died the pilot
must have maybe he was wearing a
parachute - mm-hmm okay there we got
that fixed point on the falling see if
we can track what happens to the pilot
here keep it I Oh whoopsie where's the
pile what a crazy
everybody had GoPros gosh let's just
pile it every angle they put the shots
each angle and getting the better water
for the pilot yeah yeah well there's
that that guy do you think do you think
at one point these guys are thinking I
need to get the shot and like turn to
look back for the explicit purpose no no
that's like such a filmmaker thing to do
you care about your life first your life
is the first thing yeah you look around
make sure your life is good and then if
you had audio can you hear them actually
accounting and like making sure that
they got everybody and they're landing
like is he down is he good is he good
like it every like talking like farinata
phrase if everybody's there Oh what did
you do today
Oh jump out of an exploding the plane
crash he still lands like in the doesn't
the Atlantic spot right that doesn't so
funny about it now they all got that
itch just like dude it's just not as fun
unless so recently Niko turned me on to
this channel on YouTube called Patti
Mayo
okay I know if you guys have heard of
this but since 27 the views guys don't
give him the traffic
don't tell them how much traffic it is
don't don't like oh yes and go to it
don't ya don't give so here's the deal
on on Patti Mayo let's just take a step
back and talk about this for a second
since 2017 youtuber Patti Mayo has been
producing a show that quote follows the
life of bounty hunter Patti mate Mayo in
the course of hunting down fugitives on
bond throughout California now the show
looks and feels like a real law
enforcement show you might find on a or
you're cops but they are cops but Patti
Mayo isn't a cop or law enforcement of
any kind and the show makes no
disclaimer whatsoever about being
scripted or staged how do we know it's
scripted on stage you go do I take that
so I came across this just as a random
like a video recommendation I think the
title was like guy puts me in an armbar
well on cuffs I'm like huh so I click on
it I had like 22 million views and it's
it's very much filmed like cops where
the guy he has a vest on his like bail
enforcement agency or some other like
yes where does a sheriff one to
eventually he usually just got crazy
pretending he's a cop yeah um and it's
him like you know clearly breaking the
law like trying to arrest quote-unquote
a guy who's like didn't quote-unquote
pay his bail yeah um I was like this is
weird like first off he's like pointing
a gun at the dudes like that's really
pretty illegal and like to get you in
trouble like this kidnapping charges you
could drop on something like yes not
obeying any sort of conduct yeah there's
no really clearly not however yeah wait
that Nikko did you nati discover this
and natty discovered this this isn't
through like reddit or another YouTube
video you you you were you you were
recommended this video and Adella rhythm
it was weird right so is weird so I
started looking into a little bit more
first I just look at other videos in the
most recent ones in this channel they're
all wearing sheriff uniforms and they
okay if they're waiting sheriff clothes
I know there's certain regulations like
certain procedures have to fall as a cop
and they're not following any of it so
that start to set me off too and then in
the description there's just a little
hint that says not affiliated with any
law enforcement agency so that's it
description other people have started
making videos but
ding this guy so Patti Mayo he's really
miss Patrick mm-hmm
he's actually a Youtube pranker from
Oregon and he won't see YouTube started
like D monetizing all that prank stuff
especially like the really hardcore
prank stuff that you know shooting
people were doing he was one of those
shitty people he jumped on over doing to
doing this fake cop show so he went even
deeper yeah in direction it found
casting calls for his shows on like
actors access kind of stuff with his
name his real name on it and his
girlfriend's name saying I'm shooting a
scripted you know cop style show I need
actors in it and being a filmmaker
watching it I can I can tell that it's
not real you know especially being from
there with like the the actual
procedures real police would have to go
through but people say in the comments
but the big thing is like his disclaimer
I mean there's actually a news segment
from an Oregon TV station Oregon TV
station interviewing him where he's
saying it's scripted so you have it you
know the words the problem the problem
though is that the show comes off as a
reality based law enforcement show yeah
he doesn't say they were trained you ER
and since 2017 he's amassed 5 million
subs and 400 million worldwide views so
should this be considered lying and
should YouTube shut this down
I guess the bigger questions should
YouTube deep monetize people for lying
yeah no no what I think Paula Josh would
scam Sam over lying isn't illegal
generally but it's not a matter of law
is YouTube at the point like YouTube
when it's portraying add some people the
same thing is television like if this
was on TV the FCC would come in and they
would shut it down you should definitely
do monetize people for lying yeah people
that are doing like hands to anti-vaxxer
motional videos finally got the monetize
like a few weeks ago like straight up
lying to people especially in a way that
can be like construed as like what stir
I'm looking for truth would you like hey
this is a fictional show like yeah
technically it's not a lie when you're
doing a fictional show but when you're
portraying something as being real and
it's not and you're deceiving people
that's what I'm looking for straight-up
deception shouldn't be monetize so your
own it not with pure
like first season they should be
demonetised or like remember owl and
tutorial the avant-garde tutorial thing
and then it's a channel where he
characters basically making these
hairbrained tutorials and then towards
the end like there's a weird funny
subplot that this guy Alan is trapped
and it's being held hostage and is
trying to do tutorials in his Hawks
but where does he lie in that where's
the lie with anything I'm not he's not
trapped yeah but what is all it's all
fake never like in these tutorials he's
like I can make a tutorial I'm like how
to make a pot and like then he like he
slap some butter on it gets her like
he's that lying to you I'm just saying
like bears yeah it's a gray zone do you
always have to say whether what you're
doing is a large amount of people if a
large enough amount of people would be
deceived by your actions such that like
the common person would would see that
and be deceived by it I think then
that's where you cross the line about
lip syncing well here's the thing if
alan tutorial was saying he was
kidnapped and people were believing him
then yes that can cause harm if people
are like there's a guy that's kidnapped
he's uploading videos on youtube and he
like he's not faking it there's somebody
like really in trouble we need to call
the cops and you call 9-1-1 it's like
yeah that's not okay you know I think it
can cross that line but he didn't like
Alan G toriel definitely did not cross
that line who was that original YouTube
girl that was doing the show where she
was 15 yes yeah yes scripted should we
put her in jail no no no no no no one's
going to jail I'm just saying the jail
and this none of this should be taken
off YouTube either it just shouldn't be
monetized right but that's really
rewarding people for deceiving people
because what you do is you encourage bad
behavior so what about our videos do you
have to say all all events in primitive
technology zombie meat harvester or
fictional and zombies existed in real
life is really fictional no because the
average person's not gonna look at it
and think that it's real no but we
clearly have a scripted show on I mean
corridor I don't know about this and
then you research it's fake but and so
someone can and they'll watch it know
like
most people think it's real I can think
I think this is fake and you watch the
BTS okay it's fake Sam the fact that
there's not a single disclaimer at the
beginning of any of these videos that
says this is a scripted show or a
depiction of law no one would watch it
was personal exactly exactly so that's
the point see show you for money even
you yeah it's deceit there's a part of
the clip when I watched he pulls on the
gun puts it to the window of the guy's
car cuz guy gets in the car and locks
himself he says I'm gonna blow your
brains out if you don't get out think
about a 10 year old who just watches
that video across the not knowing that
it's not a real sheriff thinking that
that's how law enforcement works and
then going yeah it's no wonder why you
know people like it's like you're
encouraging that no it's damaging this
misrepresenting police officers like
it's put him in the worst light I mean
oh there's a comment for mr. be saying
hey really appreciate and respect what
you guys are doing mr. beast on this
yeah yeah mr. beast is a whole nother
topic okay that guy this is interesting
because like there's some fundamental
stuff here
that I agree and disagree with but okay
so the question the fundamental question
is should YouTube just D monetize people
for deceit and all this deceit because
like again false representation like
this I think should be demonetized I
don't think should be removed and people
confuse D monetization with censorship
and like well it is but it isn't it's
not censorship it just means you can't
make a career out of bullshitting people
which is like a career out of snap okay
you know actually here we go you just
want me over because it's basically like
the snake-oil thing it's that it's
basically this is like idea snake-oil
were you like you think you are getting
something that is real and that's why
you like it but it's all totally BS and
people are tricking you yeah and like I
would argue that like that I don't I
mean once again don't have anything to
back it up but you bring up that mr.
beast thing and that kind of genre of
like I gave my friend a million dollars
because blah blah it's like okay first
off I don't know like like what you're
doing is real like just like this it's
it's like but by people thinking that
content is real yeah it's you get that
idea snake-oil thing again we're people
while he did this wow I don't think mr.
beast should be demonetized for
deceiving people I think you should did
be amazi monetize because it's trash
content that's my opinion on this
forever and ever I know yeah dude you're
gonna don't how dare you you compare
corridor to mr. beast you're comparing
it okay I'm saying that like thank you
that's subject in no wait you know in
our videos in no way do we try and
defend that it is real or that he really
lives in the jungle etc so there's that
but I mean mr. beast really give one of
these youtubers $200,000 for winning it
there was $100,000 per round and I don't
know to be honest with you he might have
it was sponsored by apex and so had some
prize money but there's no proof he's
just the he's just the next guy in the
line of trash humans who play people for
people's obsession with materialism is
the next guy in line
homeless man just like the most
expensive material of ice as like well I
won't claim we're gonna say most people
don't know who mr. beast is who's mr.
beast but most people know who mr. B
says he has 15 Millions I don't know
more probably know who mr. B season know
who we are
yeah well don't that's for sure actually
yeah mr. beast is basically a youtuber
like he's like at one of those mean Lord
kind of youtubers see he's like what two
hundred thousand dollar YouTube airsoft
battle royale and authorizing strangers
with hundred zombies I gave a homeless
man a home if anything still for 24
hours straight statue challenge the
comments are always like you know what
he's like doing something good for the
world and blah blah blah blah blah but
he's just playing people the whole time
so yeah mr. beast basically his his dick
is more or less getting people's
attention by spending large amounts of
money whether or not he's actually
spending large amounts of money I don't
know I quite frankly I don't think most
of us viewers really even care because
more about him going out and doing goofy
things and he also does other things
that aren't money based he's just kind
of like one of those extreme stunts er
style YouTube's I don't mean stunts in
the dangerous sense I mean remember when
we were
I have a sneaking suspicion that mr.
beast watches all of our stuff in fact I
know that he watches listens to our
podcast so I'm sorry that you're hearing
us talk [ __ ] about you but remember when
he did that whole like hey we have
30,000 miles over credit No okay so
we've in fact we had potential access
like 30,000 miles of uber credit mm-hmm
yeah we knew some mom and like would it
be funny to $30,000 $30,000 supercar
yeah like would it be funny to do an
uber ride from LA to New York and we
made a video hypothetically talking
about it and then like two weeks later
mr. beast did it so I'm pretty sure he
watches her stuff because I mean he's
directly commented on one of the podcast
episodes that was him who did it yeah oh
good for him I mean to be fair none of
us we're gonna sit in Logar for like a
week yeah but he did yeah and he got 18
million views on it I mean I don't know
if he actually sat in an uber for like
four days going across the United States
but I wouldn't be surprised but more so
I think what what mr. beast represents
is the same thing that Ryan's toys
reviews represents which is yeah here on
add altered like exploitation of
people's materialistic tendencies is to
say kids love toys and candy let's make
a video like a Suika channels all about
just toys and candy and it's the same
thing that Logan Paul said when he was
here and he said how he was gonna engage
in the drama content if that was what
people wanted to hear and but the thing
is is that at no point is the question
ever asked like what am i doing for the
world as a result of this like the
people that watch it I know I'm
exploiting them and you can sit back and
you can say well it's their fault for
watching it and it's on them because
they're the ones who turn it on and and
I'm just making it and if millions of
people want to watch it that's up to
them that's like saying that that's like
meth dealers they don't have to buy it
your distributor smoker creating it and
distributing it and you're not taking
into consideration the negative effect
it has on the world yeah so what are
what are the negative effects of
watching mr. beast look I will say to
mr. Dees credit it's his videos aren't
as materialistic as say a toy no not as
much I agree with I mean it surprising
some be 100 zombies isn't but likes
going and sitting and having
Brazilian steak dinner where one of the
Brazilian steaks is lined in gold leaf
like that's just yeah though I think I
think there are doing much better cases
of it than mr. beast because mr. beast
is clearly pushing much more towards the
inert okay fair enough do you think that
people watch these videos and they're
just like I can't just judgment
essentially like I feel like a good
portion of like Logan Paul and Jake
Paul's views are just judgment views you
know where you watch it - hey definitely
you think it's the same with this guy no
no I mean like mr. B's bought like four
seats to the Super Bowl so I get where
shirt said sub sub - PewDiePie yeah so
he does stuff like that and because of
his audience loves him for it because
I'm sure if I'm sure someone's gonna
comment about how I my opinion is
completely wrong about him but my
opinion is based upon the fact that he
doesn't make consideration for the
effect that he has on others and when as
a content creator you need to and what
effect is that it's it's basically
you're not using your voice to teach
anyone anything you're just using it to
that's fine you don't have to teach
anyone anything no I don't agree with
that I know that I think like you have
you have at least a modicum of
responsibility to create something where
when people walk away from it
it at least like doesn't make them
dumber yeah although although this kind
of reminds me of like listening to Alex
Jones talk about the idea of like this
this like the government the elite
version of the government like splitting
off from the rest of the population to
control them you know mister what if mr.
beast is a government conspiring agent
to try and help ease and create that
rift between like the easily
controllable masses and the actual like
government in the shadow government that
actually that actually runs the world -
easily my grandma said to me before I
went off to college what you said that's
the fun explanation like we're gonna
still be in school I said I'm gonna
study filmmaking she goes we're gonna do
to make the world a better place you can
be a doctor you could be a scientist
we're gonna make the world a better
place like well I'll tell storage like
stories are important but we're gonna do
make new world a better place and I was
like well I got to tell stories that are
important you know the kind that make
the world a better place just like good
also laughter laughter is the best
medicine and so that makes you even more
important when you take away all the
like interpretation of what the content
is whether it's Patti Mayo or mr. beast
and you just sit back and you and you
ask that question what does it do
mm-hmm like I just that's why I can't
never get on board with it yeah it just
doesn't do anything yeah that's fine for
you but like it doesn't have to do
anything I'm so I'm saying you can say
it doesn't have to from like sure but
I'm taking a moral stance on it you're
absolutely right and and in that taking
that stance like you're right it doesn't
have to somebody doesn't have to be
obligated to do that yeah as somebody
that but I just feel like well then
maybe that person doesn't have a soul
yeah no I agree because it's like you
know like when you're what you're kid
and you're watching Nickelodeon and they
would everyone smile they'd have these
like prizes which was like a shopping
spree and Toys R Us we could hit grab as
many toys as you wanted yeah and every
single time I saw that commercial for
that like I died on the inside because I
would want kill for that and it didn't
make me happy definitely did not make me
smarter and didn't do anything positive
for me other than like put this like
spark of like bloodthirsty rage of like
idea and jealousy and and all that stuff
and when I look at mr. beast videos I I
feel that and I see it because I'm not
I'm like it's not funny it's not like
humor it's not entertainment it's like
something that prods you deep inside and
like makes you like forces you to watch
it because yeah I I would I want to kill
all these people who are in this they're
all trying to be better than me like I'm
not I'm not my mole yeah yeah especially
when you look at but that's even more
distilled in those like toy channels the
unboxing channels with all that are far
worse offenders in my opinion although
this this is this kind of like this is
like this
two beasts channel in a way though it's
like he kind of he's like oh yeah you
think I can you think toys are the only
thing they'll create that feeling it's
like watch how creative I can get I mean
the mr. B's channel that to me it's it's
fantasy fulfillment it is what's a
what-if channel yeah if I gave ten gun
into a stream exactly reaction you know
and just an experiment I have to I have
to fully disclose like it's not it's
like I don't want to be reg and too hard
on this channel cuz like as I go through
it it's like there are some really
interesting concepts that are being
played out here but it does I am just
saying it it does start to tap into that
concept and there's plenty other people
who out there out there who are actually
truly guilty of that kind of explain so
I don't want to just like lay it all
down on this guy's channel because it's
not I don't think that's fair - alright
anyways let's leave it there I think the
closing comment is if you are exploiting
a homeless person for views by giving
them something
I think that's distasteful and it's very
generous of you to give them something
but I would rather you see it I'd rather
see you do it in a way that doesn't
profit that you don't either if not see
you do it I'd rather you just do it out
of the goodness right heart yeah it's
like you guys ever watched Curb Your
Enthusiasm there's a really great scene
where Larry David you know those boys
are like at this like function and
they're both looking up there to like
all this this donor wall and they're all
like man I wonder what it take to get up
there and they like oh look anonymous
and one of them's like yeah that's me
cool and then they all start like like
paying more to get in on it now that
they know that's the race they're like
I'm changing my name to anonymous so but
I'm but and then telling everyone that
it's the idea that you you do it under
this facade that you're doing something
for somebody else but you're really
doing it for yourself right and that's
what disturbs me about it anyway moving
on agree all right
something's happening in the streaming
world guys okay first and foremost deals
are all the sound effects guys
[Music]
Disney announced just earlier this week
that it is acquiring well it's already
announced that it's acquiring but as its
announced the deal by 21st Century Fox
for 72 billion with a b-boys is expected
to become effective next week so they're
gonna by 20th Century Fox which will
give them control of avatar and also
film rights to a number of Marvel
characters including Fantastic Four
x-men and Deadpool and in addition to
this this is all pretty much in a ramp
up to the launch of their streaming
service Disney Plus which obviously is
going to be a competitor to Netflix and
will produce original shows and movies
for the service Disney Plus such a
boring name yeah so so with all that
going on sigh things go well that going
on at the same time
Apple is expected to announce on March
25th that it too is going to unveil a TV
streaming service oh my god Apple
originals Apple original well they
haven't they don't have a name for it's
just expected we're going to start with
a Beatles documentary John lemon and so
hey so is this finally the culmination
of what started about 12 years ago now
yeah with this like actually the final
the final big boys such as Disney and
Apple coming into the streaming world
Disney now owns media period like the
concept of media by trade market like
literally they're the monopoly on media
their trademark react media trademark
the numbers 16 by 9 okay so what's the
fear Disney takes over they buy
everything what's the what's the fear I
mean that that inning yeah I think to me
the big question is at what point does
popular culture become owned by the
culture and not by the company that made
it at what point is a lightsaber owned
by all of us who enjoy and live in our
fantasy world of Star Wars and not by
diseases you can't use that you know
well I think I think I think it's it's
two things
one okay so the concept of using like
it's just the concept of a visual medium
that Disney is basically trying to
dominate you know and this is that next
step in it and if you look at like any
other industry in the world you know it
starts it starts out there's a lot of
healthy competition and then it slowly
starts converging in towards a few few
people here yeah and I think when people
react to Disney and all this stuff it's
like well first there's YouTube that's
the that's that's not Disney right now
YouTube is the daytime television of the
media world pretty much well I'm saying
it's like right now it's basically it's
you have currently it's Netflix and
YouTube are like the two ways that
people generally watch media yeah and
this might become well Disney's doubling
at stake in Hulu with this acquisition
of 24 size boxes they're gonna be the
majority owner with 60% sure sure I'm
just getting it I've just been
high-concept here it's like well if
you're not into Disney you know maybe
try books you know or virtual reality of
video games with like on Steam with
using a vibe you know it's like those
are good alternatives now to like art
what we've visited media for I wonder 2d
Disney like if it's 2d on a screen and
moving that's busy now you know like at
the end of the day if it creates another
like what people experiment distribution
platform for movies and shows there's a
few of them there's Netflix there's HBO
now and there's like Hulu and the
theaters and yeah and the theaters right
yeah and then and then you have like
traditional like pay for TV cable but
this at least this will create another
place where people can look and go hmm
Disney Plus is making an original show
or an original movie or whatever and if
it gets on there it's considered by the
says people that don't know anything
about media whatsoever to consider to be
legitimate yeah so it does do that for
people like us it does but it creates
another avenue for us to tell stories on
yeah absolutely because arguably
there'll be more opportunity there than
the traditional Disney TV and film
routes yeah and I think the more flavors
the better like iTunes and Disney like
they're basically it's just more more
avenues for content yeah opportunities
for content creators and yeah I think I
think they'll keep each other in check
hopefully if you have like three four
five there is a yeah
you know like they'll they'll they'll
balance each other but they are gonna
try to kill one another for sure they're
everyone's competition yeah because
right now if you talk about that
assuming that apples is successful
you're talking about Apple Disney Plus
Netflix Apple I don't think Apple
YouTube put YouTube in there because I
could be wrong but I do service yeah go
anywhere I'm ready for a die I'm ready I
marked it didn't ready I'm ready I'm
just like freaking this is like the day
back in 2008 when we marked the top
price in gold do you remember that day
knows high high prices like Alma it
almost hit 2k and we're like that's it
it's done it's done forever and it never
ever got back there yeah I think there
probably never will until inflation
karriesue me not for another 30 years or
something tell the next great in the
economy exactly
but yeah I don't know whatever so that's
that's neat I guess but I don't know
it's like every time I watch it is like
an actual Disney movie at this point I
feel like I'm just like buying into some
like PC like 21st century ideology king
of these speaking of that are you gonna
watch the Aladdin live-action movie
because they just dropped the trailer
looks so jank okay it's got it's guys
the movies coming out May 24th it stars
Meena Masood as Aladdin I only Scott as
jasmine and of course Will Smith well
they didn't actually watch Beauty and
the Beast no no don't care like Aladdin
was my next to Mulan those are my two my
two favorite Disney movies as a kid so I
just don't care about the live-action
Aladdin to be honest it's like one was
less I miss the cartoon version
anyways there's yours the things with
this like with a lad and it's like it's
pretty much just a straight-up
live-action remake as you can tell but
like if we're all the production quality
it has it still has this vibe of just
being a really expensive fan film it
looks cheap and fake the kinda it's kind
of got the same gimmick that we
basically did for video games in
corridor which is like well we just made
a live-action version of that video game
yeah we just made a live-action version
of our card so you can't help but see
like oh we can make money by doing this
so let's make money like where where's
the art you know like of course to bring
the rain people that's what they're
doing yeah but it's like cuz they can't
afford to take huge risks on things that
don't have a market already anymore
which is the way that they the way that
they drove movies and bigger and bigger
and bigger what they call Marvel thing
that the Marvel thing is perfect for
them because they're like oh wait you're
telling me that there's this huge
pantheon of stories that have existed
for 50 years and we'll never run out of
stuff yeah and they're like it's perfect
no it makes sense is a business it makes
sense I mean Marvel movies at this point
it's just a movie format of a television
show you know I don't know should I
isn't really worth complaining about
because I think you can also really make
a solid argument for saying Ah people
telling the same damn stories for a
thousand years
look people slitting the bible's like
really dope and enriching you know it's
like stories have been with us for a
really long time there's a story the
story is based on the 40 thieves and
they written a thousand and one Arabian
Nights exactly written in the Middle
Ages exactly and then there's other
stuff before that those pretty similar
you know about the origin of that story
you know but it sounds always like there
was a king who the the origin of the
thousand Arabian Nights is that there
was a king who wanted to be entertained
by a woman basically and each night I
knew he took him with that I took him
back for a wife or something he was
going to kill her ya know and so each
night a woman would tell him a story and
then sleep with him and then the next
morning if he decided that the story
wasn't good enough he'd kill him and he
did this a thousand nights in a row wait
I sure I I thought it was different no
he killed a thousand women no I thought
it was that I thought was like fighting
nights I thought is that like a thousand
like fighting soldiers he would actually
in the next day when this woman decided
that the only way she can keep that from
happening is to tell him store like tell
him a story that's so good that he needs
to sorry right that that's true but the
thing is that's why it's a thousand yes
because she tells a story that just goes
on forever and ever and ever
but then he kills her does he I don't
know I don't think anything like a
pretty story to tell
one of the stories Oh thousand stories
yeah there's a whole bunch of like you
know the term Open Sesame have you -
yeah oh I have two copies of it I'll
bring you no no I was about to go on
Amazon that's even better thousand Bank
seriously just it's just one of the
videos that she's made so go check out
the rest of my YouTube on the 40 thieves
that's where Open Sesame comes from his
Alibaba was a poor man who was hiding in
the bushes when a bunch of thieves ran
by to Iraq and then said Open Sesame and
he went in the cave and found it was
their gold cave that nobody ever
questioned about Aladdin which country
does it take place in Saudi Arabia I
would say if I had to guess I would say
like Pakistan or Afghanistan yeah it
kind of looks quite like Indian like
Pakistan yeah Chinese and we're just so
Western that we're like yeah Pakistan
it's just the story is actually like
back then it was already a mash-up of
different cultures it's like Chinese
always been like this mashup okay but it
is like when you watch the movie it's
clearly one of these made-up cultures
that doesn't quite actually exist yeah
partially partially Chinese same thing
with like I didn't know this but you
know like Tiki culture that's entirely
made up Tiki culture it doesn't come
from any yeah it's world war two people
made it up Yessica Lee along with
there's no what's the famous drink don't
exist aren't Tiki culture
what's the totems they never use like
they don't use like luau like earth like
was the flower that's ladies have you
ever heard one have you ever heard of a
zombie drink it's like a cocktail made
of rum and a bunch of other stuff and
they serve that tiki bars sure yeah that
like a mai tai my time yeah all of those
drinks were created in like post-world
War era maybe there was slightly before
but basically like around that time
right all that whole culture was created
like sure it's not like wooden faces on
your Tiki cups like that's not pulled
from any culture like not like Easter
Island had anything to do with that
inspiration well I mean it's not an
actual culture so you're saying
basically Tiki culture is like Aladdin
where it's the mashup of all this
Pacific all the experiences they had it
in Hawaii on on naval bases and in
fighting in the Pacific okay okay yeah
and then they're like we love the vibes
we saw on our trip let's bring them all
home and make it yeah one single thing
instead of having to go on vacation 20
exactly that's kind of cool that's
pretty sweet actually
all right Tiki culture is real we've got
we've got do you guys are gonna pick
this one okay okay we can either talk
about the G word that's right guns or we
can talk about the other G word
geoengineering I know I know we owe
engineering I know what do you
engineering guys like guns are like so
20th century is so toys and we figure we
figured out all the rail guns now fine
we don't we don't need to talk about
guns until robots start shooting them
all right cool frequent so here we go a
new way to beat the heat guys Harvard
scientists unveil a plan to artificially
cool the Earth's climate ready for this
in a process known as solar
geoengineering Harvard scientists have
found that sprang millions of tons of
sulfate aerosols into the sky to create
a chemical canopy that reflects heat
from the Sun and effectively cools the
planet is quote technically possible
now as climate change increases its grip
on the planet researchers Harvard have
begun to take this idea more seriously
which some people including a man from
the University of Exeter who's a expert
in climate and system dynamics says the
fact that researchers at one of the
world's top universities
are costing out the deployment of such a
radical scheme shows how urgently the
climate change problem has become so the
question is should we spray or should we
pray this is like the stupidest things
I've ever heard
it's like saying it's like it's it's
literally just spray tanning the earth
is you don't it's so I mean what is what
would happen my line it sounds not chill
doesn't sound like very chill
I heard magic pills are a really good
way to lose weight in the past with
animals and introducing foreign animals
into different environments thinking
that they'll curb something and it's
just it's gone sideways well I mean like
to me this is like if I were to relate
this to after-effects
it'd be like gonna be like my rotobrush
isn't working I'm gonna have to just go
in and like hope that like my program my
programs crashing my rotobrush is like
is is Jenkin out and the only way to do
this is it's like if I hold the caps
lock and like go to the secret menu
check the secret button and then like
like like use use a like an old project
file and reload it and after that it's
like the janky aswer crown'd it feels
like I don't know do you think they
should even be costing something like
this out though I do I mean strikes me
as something as something like hey hey
mr. scientist would this cool planet
he's like I guess and like they're like
a huge article on it like it sounds to
me as like one of those like kind of BS
clickbait it sounds like some some
research assistant at Harvard working
for some PhD candidate or something like
came up with this and then look at this
Carly Kinsella the idea was once taboo
but desperate times may just call for
desperate measures it's like no the idea
is - no it's still taboo like are you
dumb like all these just in rank we
sprayed one thing into the environment
that made it bad you think spraying a
second thing is gonna make it better
right yeah
and carbon subsidies fossil fuel
subsidies yeah and start adding
that's it the magic pill thing just put
our subsidies into some other place
because that's the only reason I think
you fix it by promoting technological
and economic advancement see right off
of exactly you take the subsidies that
the oil companies get and then just put
them into another area that you think
could use more research done right no no
that's gonna foster because you create
artificial incentives when you do that
well you create artificial incentives
when you give them the subsidy situation
it's like pre valuation money in a
business though and like things like the
Continental railroad would have never
got built if it hadn't been for like the
government using money to do that so you
need you need them to sort of prop up
people to be incentivized to start
researching like hey what does it look
like if we do this or if we start this
way if we use water this way or that way
and we we better utilize energy and then
from there then you let the businesses
take off but you have got to be
attacking that the problem from all
angles right and instead of just giving
away subsidies to businesses that are
already in place but yeah you know
exactly that's Ralph I think people
would go oh I think people would started
voting for people who are into I guess
solving or at least dealing with climate
change if they actually got to feel the
full price of what oil costs them how do
you do that put them in a barrel no and
the subsidies for fossil fuels home in a
barrel for that barrel instead of 50 all
right well that's it I mean we solved
solar geoengineering so we determined
that Disney's new thing might be good or
bad we we just resolved what would
happen if you were behind a Boeing 737
max 8 and of course we've determined
that Sam's okay with cheating to get
into college I did say okay with
cheating I'm saying I'm okay with being
people paying a little extra a little
extra
add a $30,000 check in the envelope oh
yeah there's a reconsider fee remember
guys consideration for $300,000 yeah all
right we're making all this photoshopped
photo of him racing a car this is really
fun if you guys enjoyed this video or
this podcast definitely let us know cuz
I like this format we should probably do
more of them next time we talk about
space travel and extra dimensions and
what you have on the surface ain't what
dwells beneath pal and crazy plan a
crazy plan to uh I don't know solve
other some worthless other world
problems or something to impact the
world's most badass meme is how to eat
chips with no teeth time Nikko dietz's
you have eat chips silently that's great
oh hey guys subscribe hit that Bell you
know there's two options on the bell now
that's right you can click it and you'll
see this two different options sometimes
now he's never sometimes sometimes
always never keep great ringing the bell
until you're satisfied yep fairly
subscriptions
well that's they have to click to find
out it's a little mystery oh I'm trying
to incentivize our audience to click
that bells you know what yeah you know
YouTube told me subscriptions
they're just like they're just like the
like button they don't matter it's the
notifications that are the new
subscription yeah and only one of the
notifications actually counts yeah you
bring the Bell until you disco for the
truth turn on that o is bell boys
alright thanks for watching